dans cette école de Prague résonne un
champ ukrainien
un lien que ces jeunes réfugiés peuvent
conserver avec le pays qu'ils ont fui
[Applaudissements]
chaque soir après les cours des ateliers
parascolaire sont offerts
certaines séances comme celle de Charles
guitare sont organisés par des Russes
notre guilty responsable rashion people
et nous nous demandions ce que nous
pouvions faire explique-t-il
vit en République tchèque depuis
plusieurs années avec d'autres
ressortissants russes il a recueilli des
fonds pour tenir ses activités
sans amis ces jeunes qui maîtrisent
difficilement la langue de leur pays
d'accueil vivent dans des conditions
difficiles
culturels mais aussi des cours de langue
offertes au réfugiés de tous les âges
des activités auxquelles contribuent
aussi des organismes tchèques
[Musique]
peuvent rencontrer les autres ici faire
des amis
en République tchèque ou vivre plus de
30 000 russes les voix critiques du
Kremlin sont nombreuses
[Applaudissements]
pour se poser à la guerre en Ukraine
certains ont choisi de manifester mais
aussi de prêter main forte au réfugiés
et toi c'est space
à l'aide dedans puis éventuellement d'un
appui financier du gouvernement avait le
skin a mis sur pied ce centre
d'hébergement il accueille 70 personnes
des femmes et des enfants
qui vit ici avec ses trois enfants
même s'il s'oppose à la guerre pavèle
installé à Prague depuis 14 ans
reconnaît que le contact avec certains
Ukrainiens un peu parfois être
compliqués
les liens se sont ici en dépit des
nationalités
de l'aide qui lui est apportée
ou anglais l'important c'est de faire le
bien
entre ukrainien et russe de Prague se
tissent une forme de cohabitation loin
du front de la violence et des tensions
[Musique]
ici Raphaël Bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada après
[Applaudissements]